how about the if and ends in here is it
garbage if you don't have asthma but you
keep an inhaler on you for street fights
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you [ __ ]
who are you Bane
let me get two plus I'ma knock you the
[ __ ] out
I'm about to primate team miss the [ __ ]
out of you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] them out [ __ ] anybody got a
puffer
what that that is man
do you get in a lot of street fights
[Music]
that guy was like what the [ __ ] do you
say dude he has it on him yeah man what
are you expected to happen here tonight
he looks around
what was the last street fight you got
into
how old are you
38 what we're still leaving the house
ready to go
my kind of guy yeah
that was the thing
never happens dude
that net no one's ever really see that
guy just stand there mind his own
[ __ ] business
who's ready to fight because he's got an
inhaler on him
let's get that guy let's get him and
how'd you do did you take care of him
nine out of ten doctors recommend
just get a knife dude what are you doing
get a gun what are we doing it's in
America
oh man give him a [ __ ]
that's what I'm talking about
I told you Nashville came to [ __ ]
play dude that's beautiful
where's Michael P at
Mikey there he is what's up big man how
you feeling now what kind of work do you
do
all right thanks where'd you go to
college
okay what school in New Jersey
I think he made that up I'll be honest
with you also also I went with a
follow-up when you asked him what school
he went to when he gave a state
he's not looking for follow-up questions
there where did you go to school New
Jersey keep it moving
how'd you do in high school
you didn't take anything that sounds
like Ocean County New Jersey
Ocean County College no tests needed
come on in how do you get the couch and
I'm taking the SAT he opened the door
what are you talking about
and so you grew up in Jersey
nice it'd be weird if you went to a
community college in Jersey from
Nashville
ma your baby boy's going to college
a thousand miles away
and I didn't even take the SATs God damn
it
find out it was online
the server was in New Jersey uh no uh
who are you here with your your newly
wed wife
where was The Wedding just stop asking
questions okay
okay
are you garbage if you come to a live
show the day after you get back from
your nine-day honeymoon at Disney World
enduring adoring hurricane Ian
I wanna I hope that you saw hurricane
was coming it's like babe pack your bags
they're slashing prices down there
it's cheap I got a five thousand dollar
vacation for 1800. he did send pictures
of them too with the ears on and
everything
you guys are standing at nine feet of
water
I was promised breakfast with the
characters
I youtubed your Disney adults
where was the wedding at now I can ask
you where was the wedding
that's the nice part of Alabama right
that sounds like the nice part
was that was there a cash bar or you pay
for all that no
no alcohol are you guys 11 What's
Happening Here
is it what's the legal age of marriage
down here
can I stumble into something
can I ask you this how much did you guys
make off the wedding Cash Wise enough
for nine days in a hurricane
[Applause]
hit me with a number
25 G's
2500.
that's where you get that serving booze
dude yeah
give him a nice round of applause that's
beautiful
and we're half the problem with you
congratulations congratulations the
newlyweds love it
so you can catch him at Six Flags next
week
for the christening